so back in the day jingle jingle jingle
back in the day before the back rooms
were a thing okay pet jingle jingle pay
attention pay attention I said your
favorite word the back rooms okay the
back rooms dingle dangle dingle dangle
okay before that was the thing the
concept of a place with endless
impossible oh dingle dangle Dingle
Dingle jingle jangle it's okay look at
the shiny before the back rooms were the
thing
The Impossible geometry of endless
landscapes
was all what SCP was about okay that's
what it was about you know single tingle
you know offices you love offices you
love endless offices
that's what this is that's what this is
except it's stay it's stairs it's stairs
jingle jingle jingle jingle it's stairs
it stairs stairs so it's endless stairs
just as boring as offices and I know how
much you love boring offices I know you
love that you love the back rooms you
love the back rooms can't get enough of
the what's the anomaly in the back rooms
wow
back in the old Yonder years of so long
ago literally ancient history 2012.
we're talking two zero one two so far
ago okay pay attention it's it's gonna
be all worth it this this
was the the originator the ancient
ancestor you dig up the bones you go
down deep in the sedimentary layers of
horror on the internet you'll get this
uh don't forget to ignore everything
below it that don't matter oh I hit my
there we go all right so now we're going
back in time but this is the extended
edition get ready for even more Spooks
even more terrible things like this too
try not to scream
oh
wow I just remembered something about
this game
the absolute astonishing level of mouse
sensitivity and somehow being flicked
behind me with everything don't scream
don't scream it's okay it's gonna be
okay because uh better be careful hold
up hold up oh I'm sorry I could
whatever you say big gay I wasn't gonna
stop anyway so you go down and down and
the numbers get scarier and uh it's
gonna be all right guys it's going to be
all right don't worry it gets scarier is
that a four or is that an is that a
penis it looks like a penis actually if
you think about it I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get age restricted that is
straight up a penis that ain't no four
I've seen fours before that ain't a four
anyway
I know guys I know it's a terrifying
penis the scariest thing in anatomy but
you guys gotta gotta be bravery gotta be
brave for me
good luck I know I'm going to need the
good luck
because as we start to descend down into
the depths of hell
things get even worse
like this six or is it a nine that's
upside down calm down
be very careful if you could stop
screaming for just a moment you might
realize that there's a monster standing
directly behind you a five that's not
scary you're braver than I because watch
out for this one
that's a perfectly formed seven
just like Lord minion 777 the star oh my
God
the star of such hit shows
oh [ __ ] that's destructible
well
[Music]
this is now rapidly becoming a big
problem but alas looks like I won't be
going back
oh the drugs hit Drive dead
oh
I have a match apparently
that's how I see things with matches
okay now is I think when death could
lurk around no hate right
oh frick
I did I actually just remembered
something
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I remember I remembered that
like when it's not a stare there's
something that I gotta be careful about
I'm getting like vot
[Music]
Ed
what in the hell was that
anyway there's something about this
where it's like if either you you look
down away or you go away and you don't
go down a path I'm like I'm connecting
to my my 2012 self okay this is many
years ago that I gotta tap into
knowledge that I don't have anymore and
what it amounts to is that game that
also is the extended edition and I don't
know what else is there in the extended
edition
okay all right hold on
Frick left I wasn't expecting that
yeah
fine
it's all good baby
oh it's all good
[Music]
I don't like big room I remember big
room wait do I not look at something in
the big room do I not look at anything
in the big room what happens in the big
room
hey
go ahead
oh [ __ ] I'm dead
am I dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm fine
nine
nine give it up for nine
is this back room's DLC oh God damn okay
hey
why didn't the freaking goopy hell
okay all right
all right listen they're saying you're
this ain't your Grant this ain't your
grandma's back rooms okay this is your
grandma's backrooms okay this is
remember your your ancient great grandma
this is what she played back when she
made horror videos on the internet
okay
you thought the back rooms was spooky if
you did you got issues jingle jangle
this is a little bit more uh down than
that one that was that way this is that
way
all right I'm going I don't know what
any of the noises are and that's my
least favorite part of playing a horror
game is not knowing what the noises are
because when I don't know what the
noises are I don't know what's gonna
kill me I don't know what's lurking
behind me
turn
ten we did the ten
[Music]
death could be lurking around any for
every corner
oh what did I just say
on a scale of one to ten how many of you
saw something in front of me
saw something
I know I did
11 11.
11.
fine stop that why does it do that don't
do that
don't do that don't do that at all okay
we
sailed right past 11. we're at 12 baby
we're at 12.
all right same as he says before it's
big samsies it's huge saves these energy
foreign
oh my God what do I do
[Music]
is what I would ask myself
if I didn't have so much piss in my
pants
I thought they got me
truth was no
[Music]
the easiest thing actually
all right
13.
stop that wait that's that sound that
sound that's the is that from SCP
Containment Breach or am I
am I being stupid
all right I guess I'll keep going then
turns out people are dying in here or
something
why
oh frick well that's probably fine
yeah I thought that that definitely
sounded like radical Larry for a moment
there oh well it's Scooby behind me uh
14 I'm gonna go now I'm gonna go now I'm
going now
I'm going I'm going we're going we're
going fast
we're only about 15 15 give it up for 15
15s the one I like 15 baby
fifteen fifteen fifteen fifteen sixteen
sixteen sixteen we're blasting through
now 16. we ain't stopping we're going
we're going baby
we're going oh 17. dude I'm going well I
ain't stopping I'm not stopping
are you gonna stop
hmm
18 we can vote
[Music]
oh
okay 18. so anyway let's just take a
nice breather here and let's think about
where we are and what we're doing with
our lives okay if you really think about
it there's really nothing else that we
can do here we might as well just camp
out here till the rest of our days and
we might as well die because some of you
may not realize but the end could come
for us at any moment at this juncture
when I played this last before the
extended edition there were about
there were over a hundred levels with
which I could go down into and now seems
that we are only at 18 but at 18 we
could die over and over again endlessly
looping in a nightmare of Destruction as
our bodies slowly
disintegrates against the brick of the
walls
it's only way
just go
I don't want to go I want I like taking
breaks and stuffing was this so wrong is
that so wrong for me to stop and talk to
you is that so wrong for me to just talk
have a good conversation with my
audience with which I love very deeply
and dearly
oh
what is that oh what is that
all right fine all right but if I die if
I die on this next Corner if I die
you gotta go listen to distractible
that's the deal if I die I you gotta go
okay
come on die
[ __ ] I told you oh oh
oh
foreign
I told you I told you how many years
have I been playing horror games for
okay how many years and what you don't
listen to me you never listen you never
I've got instincts about this [ __ ] I
know when there's something about to be
around the corner I know it
oh freak oh frick oh frick
[Music]
you don't get it
you don't get it you don't just don't
get it do you oh frick what is this
oh I don't remember this
[Music]
I don't remember it
I don't remember this
I don't remember this
oh frick yeah 19 huh
okay
20 20 money
20.
20 20 20.
okay
21 21
.
21
all right
man I forgot that this game actually is
legitimately terrifying there's
something about it because what it what
it cap
what it capitalizes on is something that
I do not see in a lot of horror games
despite the the prevalence of horror and
the genre
it is very difficult to capture the
feeling of not one
but um
why why is that website why why why did
that open why I got I gotta
saying what you saying to me
escape to continue hold on hold on hold
on hold on
hold the phone
what
this game manages to capture that a lot
of games do not
and I'm dead serious about this is the
feeling of not wanting to move forward
to not want to go into the darkness
and the unique thing about this game is
that it is very much the same for the
majority of it and yes poor scares wear
off
all the time and you get used to things
and that's fine it's part of the game I
get that but what this game offers is
like this extended elongated sensei
yeah what the goddamn hell
is someone breathing on my neck you saw
my inside someone breathing on my neck
why is
am I breathing
why is any of this happening
I'm gonna go for it going forward
oh I know that wait oh God wait oh God
oh my God
oh my god did I almost die holy [ __ ]
what
oh my God
oh no
oh frick me
I don't know why and I don't remember
what it is
but in that last level there was an
indentation on the wall on the right
there was an indentation
and I don't know why I don't remember
why it's bad but it's bad the
indentation on the wall is bad I had
this deep chill in my soul remembering
why that was bad or not why that was bad
but that that was bad I don't remember
why it's bad but it's bad
Frick me
and I knew that if I lingered at that
indentation I would die I don't remember
why but I know that if I did
I got another bet
all I'm getting is bad vibes I've got an
I've got a Non-Stop stream of bad vibes
just bad vibes
nothing but bad bad vibes it's it's bad
Vibe Central 20.
bad vibes
bad bad
ready to leave our 20s here
what was that what
you
doing
oh no
what is that
what is that what is that hello
I don't remember that okay everybody I
don't remember what this is
I don't know what this is I don't know
what that is I don't want to know what
that is but I have a funny feeling it's
at eye level right so if I look in that
thing I'm gonna die
that's how many things work in this game
you look you die you don't look that's
that's the key when there's the monster
standing right behind you which there is
breathing on your neck
you don't look that's it you don't look
so I'm not gonna look
I'm not gonna look you don't look you
don't look you don't die that's just how
it is that's how it is I'm not gonna
look
oh Frank I didn't look
I didn't look
I didn't look that was just a normal
noise I've heard that a million times in
SCP Containment Breach see then do that
one
oh this is different
wow wow
you are now inside the
scp-0870 please proceed with caution I
didn't look
oh no I didn't look I swear I didn't
look
oh I think I was supposed to turn around
and run and I didn't have the instincts
to do that guys I didn't I didn't have
the capability give it up for two two
maybe two
holy [ __ ]
laughs oh my God
I haven't been spooked like that in a
while
holy [ __ ]
ah
okay so if that happens
turn around and run is the recipe
all right
yeah I know he was fast he was way
faster than before
oh that was no bueno that was no good
I was no good
oh
I looked into his eyes I should the
radio signal seems
you got it I'm running for it if I just
run straight down
I'll get to where I need to go in no
time
easy
thank you appreciate it
really do preach that oh
Lord
okay
what is oh no
no
oh you can't do this on the first
one
all right guys
oh my God okay here we go left or right
left or right okay
let me pause it
I gotta do a poll guys we just we gotta
do a poll
we just got to do a poll
is left to right
okay
no don't let me down on this cause I
gotta follow what you do I gots to
follow and when I follow
I'm better not die
okay
okay
I'm not even gonna read what the answer
is out loud in case it changes actually
it seems to be overwhelming in One
Direction
which either says you know something I
don't know
and you're trying to kill me or you know
the right answer
and I don't know which I hate more
okay I'll trust you
I'll trust you
for some reason I trust you
[Music]
oh good we're alive
wait a minute
oh
oh God
I thought I thought I was doomed you got
it yeah
ah that was oh
what are you doing what do you think
you're doing you think you're scaring me
with your stupid face and smile
not today
not today not today
is it always left I remembered face
I'm running
thank you
all right fun
okay so is it
yeah this is live uh is it always left
when we do that thing is that always
what it is cause
I hope so I hope so
I hope so
all right
other than that it's just gonna be
random spooky clunks and bangs and Booms
hey it's all good
it's all good
doesn't matter who's screaming in the
Darkness
because I'm screaming in my head
and then that's all gonna be
you guys have no idea what you're
talking about in the comments yeah I
know that fully and I know that
extremely you guys have no idea what
you're talking about
so I'm just gonna Press On
as if everything's fine I hate it God
even in the extended edition they didn't
change it so that the music just doesn't
always drop out every minute and a half
but it's cool it's cool we got a lot of
distance to cover
we got a lot of distance to cover 17
baby 17.
in front of me in front of me in front
of me
what where
you [ __ ]
you bag of dicks you think you can scare
me
you can't I don't think so I don't think
so you I'm way too
uh
what
oh
oh
oh
up up up up up or go up oh yeah up and
then down
and then down some more
give it up for 19. okay
I don't know why see that that's the
thing about this game right that's the
thing about this game is it even
something as simple as stairs going up
that's not right that don't feel right
nothing about that is right everything
about that is wrong you go down I go
down that's what I know about this game
I go down I go down and I keep going
down and if I stop going down for even a
second I got my dog
life if I go up again
like if I tried to turn around and go
okay
oh
frick
here we go again another
oh
are we gonna do another poll
look I I don't know what is correct
right I remember that there was a way
that I figured it out before I
remembered that in the past in the way
way back Yonder years of forever ago
before distractible before three pains
before go my favorite sports team before
any of this I remember in The Way Way
Back
that you could freaking do the thing
now you don't know which it is
God
huh
also is gifting memberships a thing now
I'm not asking for it but we were
streaming distractible uh on the YouTube
channel over there and someone gifted
gifted not Subs but Nevers I didn't
think that was a thing oh you guys
aren't any help
at all it's a thing now
that's cool
I guess now that twitch is exploding
in the YouTube needs to catch up you
guys are completely unhelpful it says
left 52 right 48 why
is it different
is it different
all right I'll just do it I'm just doing
it
you guys it is technically more left
than right imma go left
and hopefully I'm right
it's real dark down here
I'm gonna go left left
we go
oh frick I'm dead
you bags of asses you dick monsters
how could you do that to me how could
you do that to me
yeah I trusted you
I put my faith in your hands I put my
faith in your hands I put my faith in
your hands and you betrayed me
you destroyed my trust
you broke my heart
it's okay I don't care anymore uh
fine
goodness it's all good I'm cool and cool
I'm cool
God I'm cool
[Music]
I'm going in again and this time I'm
going in with a hardened heart my heart
is hard my heart is so hard I've never
had a harder heart
I'm immured if you don't know what a
mirror it is Google it I'm a mirror to
pain that I have felt before
sounds like a you problem sounds like a
me problem sounds like a you are lovely
and should deserve all the happiness in
the world
sounds like you deserve to live a full
life to the best of your ability and I
will cherish every moment of success
that you have
I will celebrate in the back ground
clapping furiously for your amazing
achievements that's what I'll do for you
that's what you deserve
on the wall
all right so it's I know that it is kind
of RNG but I remembered I connected with
my past self and I do remember what I
did to alleviate those symptoms of death
that I was feeling and I remembered I
scooched on my tippity toes and I looked
with my peepers and I was like maybe
there's something horrible over there
maybe there's something dastardly in
Devil ish and if I see it before I walk
into it I can't die and that's exactly
what I did
and so that's exactly what I'll do again
because I remember very
very distinctly that is the thing that
causes me the most deaths in this game I
don't know about the extended edition I
don't know about what new stuff lay
lurking deep below the levels here
I know it's probably bad I know I'm
probably gonna die but I know that I'm
gonna be okay about it [ __ ]
you got here quick
you got here real fast
and now I'm gonna die
right are you sure are you sure it's
right are you absolutely sure are you
sure are you sure are you sure
you better be sure if you're not sure I
swear if you're not sure and you tell me
to go right and you're not absolutely
sure about it
I will destroy you
I will destroy you I won't destroy
everything about you and everything you
know I will annihilate you if it's not
right here in this moment
oh God not again
am I dead
everybody
[Music]
know
s
did I not have to jump in the hole
did I not have to did I not have to die
in that moment did I notice
[Music]
please pursue perceive caution
guys guys I I don't I can't jangle I can
only jingle so much more this is your
grandma's back rooms this is the backest
of rooms in the farthest back rooms
this is here lurking waiting for you to
find it okay
okay
I didn't
[Laughter]
I didn't bend my knees
foreign
I'd like to think that was the only
thing separating me from Death was just
oh
I hit it straight legs my knees exploded
backwards it was my own fault oh man if
only it could have been avoided oh such
a shame
oh such a shame such a sham
and down we continue
down we continue into the deep dark
level eight
that's fine
I think
I haven't heard that one before
that was news to me
that was definitely a news to me
okay
so
so long as we can just continue
onward with no weird breathing behind my
neck
we will be just fine
to ask a lot of breathing
but I ain't scared we're on 12 12 baby
keep going for it don't look don't look
don't change don't deviate
I know that one is just straight ahead
we don't deviate we don't do anything we
just go straight ahead the only way out
is straight through there that one's
easy
this is easy
twists and turns nay no problem not for
me oh God it's fine
all good
it's fine screens that's fine
14 baby 14 we got 14.
14. 14 cleared 14 done
15 baby
I'm feeling the 15. I'm loving the 15.
16.
even better
something feels different about this
something feels different something
visually something something looks
different
there was some clue right there was
something I could see
there was something I could see
the
wasn't there something to see there was
there was some way
there's some way to know there is some
way to know there's something to know I
can know I know I can know
I know I can know there's something
about it there's something different
there's some there's something
something to hear everybody shush
[Music]
[Music]
sorry something broke over there
my God shut up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
they look exactly the same and they
sound exactly the same
through the middle like Harry Potter
oh my God I don't know
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know that's the thing I don't know
right right right it was I died right
last night it's got to be right it's got
you
oh it's right it's right it's so right
it's right it's right right it's right
right is right right is the right one
huh
that's that's how I can know if I go
down the right tunnel and I peer around
the corner and if I don't see a wall
around the corner then I know that it's
gonna kill me
that's how I know
right gang was right all along
right gang had it right all along
what well oh
my God please don't do this oh my God
left gang was a bunch of losers I should
have known
I should have known because left starts
with an l and so does losers
left was purely for losers
God right Gang has never been more right
than in this moment and ever kill me
yeah I don't know the opposite don't do
that
maybe left gang had it
maybe left gang had it after all
maybe left gang was the true you know
maybe L didn't stand for losers maybe L
stood for
um
a little Lamborghini
Lambos for everybody in left gang who
knew
they were really there
everyone left gang had Lambos it was so
clear
how did I not know
lucky left
that's not normal that's not a normal
sound
[Music]
that's just breathing it's breathing
it's breathing no it's not it oh my God
it's not a normal sound
oh what do I do oh God it's the
indentation on the wall what do I do oh
God what do I do this is bad oh this is
oh what do I do I don't even remember
what to do I don't remember what to do
what do I do it's on the right I should
have known the indentation is on the
right right is the wrong right is so bad
right is not the good one right is the
opposite of the truth oh my God what do
I do I don't remember what I do don't
look at it is that all like do I run oh
frick what do I do
oh freak what do I do don't look just
run just run oh frick oh God oh God
oh God
go
what is this what is this what is this
nonsense
what is this nonsense what is this
supposed to be
[Music]
what is this nonsense
what is this do I go left or right this
is the ultimate test oh my God are you
kidding me this this is a different left
to right
is this really what it is
is this really what I have to face
oh frick
I don't know what to do
left never fails
or right to become really rich
yeah
yeah
you ever think about that
you ever think about that
might be
you know if you know what I'm saying it
might be that way
it might be that way you ever think
about that
think about that
all right
left to this I'm trusting left left is
where my heart's always been left baby
oh oh
left never let me down left all the way
baby left was definitely correct even
though I took a right there so maybe it
was but it was majority left even though
I hit a dead end and that could have
killed me easily but it it didn't so you
know that it did it ain't that way it
don't it isn't that thing it ain't 24
give it up for 24.
give it off 24.
yeah sorry right
looks like it might not have been the
right answer
oh that's fine
yeah it's probably fine
left don't lie yeah you got that right
uh sorry I didn't mean it like that
26. okay 26. doing super good sure would
be a bad time for something horrible to
happen
foreign
would be really really awful if
something terrifying happened to me
well I know the answer to this one left
all the way
left never led me astray is it the same
is this the same it's just the same it's
just right actually would have gotten me
there a lot sooner actually if
now that I'm thinking about that if
that's the same that's just the same
layout it's right would have gotten me
there just as quick
actually quicker
now that I think about it
sure would be terrible if something bad
happened
all right fine
all right 29 29 good good oh frick no
not today [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh my god
oh am I dead
um okay um I I can't run anymore
31 hey that's a new record that is a new
County record
all right let's plow on we've um
I don't know how in that first run I
didn't encounter a single
like
[ __ ] me
oh what is that what is that what is
that what is that what what is that
oh frick
oh God oh God oh God
oh frick oh God
don't look at me that's what it's saying
don't look at me
oh my God
oh my God how in the frick do I do this
okay
I don't know where I'm going
I don't know where I'm going
I don't know where I'm going I don't
know where I'm gonna go I don't know
where I'm going I I don't know where I'm
going I don't I don't know where I'm
going
so I'm just gonna look at the floor I'm
just gonna I'm
um
I'm gonna look at the floor and I'm
gonna hope for the best oh my freaking
God oh my God
what
I didn't do it
oh you have to keep looking at that one
oh you yo yeah
oh gosh and that's so logical
of course how could I be so stupid
it's fine
0870 please proceed with
culture it's because I didn't bend my
knees
it's because I didn't tuck and roll when
I fell down
it's because I didn't believe in the
heart of the cards
okay so for the don't look at me guy
you look at that one the radio signal
seems to speak
it going
huh all right so hey good to see you
thanks for joining me on this wonderful
Adventure I hope you're having a good
day I know I am uh it's going to be lots
of fun in a couple weeks Bob and Wade
are coming into town and that'll be cool
six four
good one
and uh we'll be streaming together
having a good old time
and reminiscing about the olden days and
uh
doing what we normally do on
distractible which is just goof around
have fun and live a happy fun life
you know
oh my God
that's fine probably nothing horrible is
gonna happen for a few floors so I think
I'm okay
huh
yeah it'll be super cool they haven't
been in town in a very long time and the
three of us being together in the same
room hasn't occurred in a very very long
time
also yes we are gonna play more raft
we're gonna play a bunch more of those
oh my we're okay
we're gonna play a bunch more of the
bunch more of those games don't worry
about a thing it's all it's all on the
way
it's all on the way
yep
so now
comes the
arduous process of just
continuing forward into the darkness
don't ask what the flash was it's fine
it was nothing we're on 13. give it up
for 13.
give it up for 13 because that is all
that matters
and it doesn't matter what appears in
front of us because we got our knees
bent and so long as we got our knees
bent nothing's gonna stop us
nothing's gonna get in our way
everything's gonna be a-okay
everything's gonna be just fine
you don't gotta worry about nothing
because nothing's got to worry about us
give it up for 16. we're here again at
another beautiful
floor 16.
now Dawning on me that I have not made
it very far
in this game at all
five no no no don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't don't you're doing it
you're doing the thing don't do the
thing oh 18.
[Music]
gosh that was the scariest 18 I've ever
seen in my life
you ever seen an 18 more fear
fear-inducing than that that 18 was a
jump scare if ever there was one
huh
well anyway
20.
20 baby
hey
21. let's just get drunk
21.
anyway
all right good
okay Dean was scarier than 20. yeah 18
was probably the scariest four 18 has
been the scariest floor
where the most things have happened it's
oh frick
is that a corner no
I think it's this one
I didn't see a corner there
I think
geez I'm the genius I'm the genius oh
I'm a genius
who I stopped doing wow I don't like it
is a thing I always suspected in in the
original game that there was a thing
where it would throw your mouse and make
you look in a different direction I am
not about that
I'm not about that give it up for 24.
Frick off
not today
no no way no way Jose no way Jose
oh my Jose my Jose oh no not my Jose oh
let me live oh thank you
and let me live oh my God my Jose I
didn't go deep enough okay so I just
guessed on the last one
26 give it after 26. foreign
that was the only distinction between
that the only reason I survived is I bet
my knees
[Music]
frick frick frick frick frick
frick frick frick frick frick bend your
knees frick
it's fine
[Music]
all right 29.
getting closer
feeling better feeling stronger
feeling way stronger
feeling good
and Powerful
Here Comes 30 like it was nothing
like it's easy like it was a breeze
30. no problem
no problem at all oh no no no no which
way oh frick which I don't see you where
where are you hi he's behind me
it was behind me oh I hope he's behind
me oh I almost behind me oh God I can't
run I'm dead I'm fine I'm good
so good
Bend money is real tight or real loose I
got a loose knees that's what they
always say about me loose knees
Markiplier oh he's got the loosest knees
in the West
good thing I'm so freaking loose
Loose Cannon loose is that the corner is
that the corner that's the corner is
that the corner is that the corner
that's the corner right that's the
corner that's corn yeah Corner we love
sport yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
yes okay we're good right gang okay
so I look at him
so I look at him
right
I look I'm gonna I'm gonna look right at
him I'm look
hey oh hey
how are you
hello
I'm looking at you
oh I'm looking at you
oh I'm looking
how no what what I just had this the
thing you
[ __ ]
I literally couldn't have gotten any
less close
how could I have not as close with our
god what are your clothes
I can't believe you would do that to me
I can't believe
I can't believe it oh well
oh well
what a wonderful night
what a wonderful time what a wonderful
game what a wonderful blast from the
past
have you looked in the description
have you checked out the link in the
description have you checked the
animation from yesterday the
distractible animated
Bob and wait are terrible people go
check that out you should watch that on
my channel go to my channel find that
video If you haven't watched it
animation beautiful funny hilarious then
listen to that episode of distractible
go check it out
I'm gonna go have a lovely night take
care of yourselves and each other and
remember I'll be in your closet tonight
waiting for you if you don't check out
that animation or I'll be under your bed
I won't tell you which you'll have to
pick left or right
or
you can go check out that animation and
then check out distractible
it's your choice
just be sure to Choose Wisely